well with the triple digit temperatures  area emergency rooms are seeing a lot of  heat related injuries dr paul  chesterovich the trauma and burn center  surgeon at umc  says second and third degree burns can  occur in just a minute  when those surfaces are hot because of  the heat basically any surface  in the las vegas summer that is exposed  to sunlight  for most of the day will get hot enough  that it can burn you  in a short period of time so it's kind  of like a real life game of the floor  is lava it's like touching a metal  mailbox that's been out in the heat all  day right  dr chesterwich says kids are also  susceptible to these burns when they're  playing outside  so he recommends just avoid being  outdoors between those peak hours of 2  and 4 pm